à bout de chaque commune de trente six
mille habitants
le fracas des bombes n'a jamais cessé
durant près d'un mois
jour et nuit quotidiennement
c'est l'une des banlieues de kiev où les
combats ont été les plus acharnés les
plus rapprochées
pénétrer à bou cha
vous saisi d'effroi
à moins d'un kilomètre de l'entrée de la
ville nous arrivons dans la rue ya
blonska tenu par l'armée ukrainienne
sur 300 m une vingtaine de corps de
civils
fauchés là par la guerre
ne vous approchez pas trop près on ne
sait pas encore s'ils sont piégés
l'un d'entre eux a les mains entravées
dans le dos avec un chiffon blanc une
plaie à la tête
je ne sais pas ce qu'il s'est passé
peut-être ont-ils été torturé il va
falloir enquêter
cette femme au loin sert de toutes ses
forces la main de son mari
anéantie et sans voix face à cette mort
qui l'entourent
je n'ai pas pu ces gens se faire tuer de
mes propres yeux mais je les ai vus être
pourchassé
les soldats russes sortaient leurs armes
et il disait on va vous tuer
ils arrêtaient les voitures sans raison
ils tiraient au lance-roquettes sur je
ne sais quoi c'est tout ce que j'ai vu
nos images
des habitants tétanisé ce qu'ils veulent
que tout le monde sache ce qu'ils ont
vécu ici
toutes les personnes qui se dirigeaient
dans ce secteur était abattu on était
effrayée de sortir car s'il vous voyez
tout te dire chacun et vous tirer dessus
ou famille je veux que vous vous étiez
mon visage j'ai peur qu'ils reviennent
la ville de boudhha est aujourd'hui
libérée mais ses plaies ne sont pas
prêtes de se refermer